hi guys I'm Greg and I'm dance every
dance cyber from the awesome gaming
channel that cyber channel death low
that cyber guy Instagram and Twitter and
he will be doing some streaming videos
on tgn to keep a lookout for that before
we hop it to our video for Mass Effect
Andromeda I wanted to give a shout out
to today's sponsor 1up box
what up today I'm going to show you guys
for the month that was force since this
is Mass Effect Andromeda they came with
some pretty cool [ __ ] Oh every time I
like lag on unboxing on 1up box and like
I should have done it because I think
they're so cool yeah they had a this
awesome toy not a Samuel Jackson from
Star Wars it is thin metal force awakens
Tomiko dinos old many boxes for 1up bug
I think this is a mask for Bowser that's
like ten more subscriptions that right
there and Morton there's this awesome
rubik's cube that is 30 it's like this
works like loot crate where there's like
a bunch of different items every single
month we're only like 12 bucks a month
it's amazing to top it off they have
this awesome choose shirt look at that
you got bowser on here with not r2d2
bb-8 right and c-3po this this is
totally my style you watch the movies
right I've seen some of the movies
episode 1 2 & 3 0 1 the most the one
don't count what up box guys there's a
link of the description box to see more
of what they got go to their site
referral link in the description box
menu sold like a hundred dollars hundred
boxes right there and why do a whole
unboxing video easy boats Mass Effect
Andromeda I am a huge Mass Effect fan I
know everything there is to know about
honestly you don't need to be here Dan
okay you know I'll go good we're called
the real reject because we're all about
gaming on this channel well I get why
people request that I watch these game
trailers because I know so much about
Mass Effect yeah total but now seriously
come back here what was this look okay
selfie basically this is the fourth
entry into the Mass Effect series or it
is a brand new story and it's when the
you the humans croghan Garris species
because I can't think of the name right
now course Gary come on but they go to
the Andromeda galaxy to expand and it's
the adventures that you have in a drama
Mykelti Wow a lot that could not be more
enthused down there for a reason
yes is that our whole dang world that's
habitat 7 new earth coming lucky Hiram
Agnes it is 20,000 soldiers verse 16
when the power runs out ladies I've
[Music]
gotta surrender oh please you're not
really going after you are for subtle
army sure
we've been out playing the art out of
the mattress
oh my god to change the rule
from another galaxy liner suicidal even
harder I've got a program yeah weird
everybody
[Music]
pretty sweet-looking feel good oh it's
coming out in like months and a half two
months
I don't ever yeah didn't Matt from 26 no
it's pretty cool I mean let me give my
professional opinion absolutely go for
it
totally reminded me of like a Star Trek
episode or movie not defense space but
like the whole ideas are space explorers
crashing is some villain who's like our
talkative team's medicine
I'm going to take control I can't wait
for the villain from another galaxy like
watching this back I think you kind of
like seen what the plot line is aw
that's like the best way for me to kind
of describe it for anyone that doesn't
know anything about this it's kind of
like interstellar needs Star Trek yeah
except with more guns and Grogan's yeah
yeah I got a super Star Trek line that's
what should I call this super Star Trek
no they should not
yeah I would have them sold blame one no
and they wouldn't have it a problematic
a nostalgia strong bond I'm very getting
upset about it what doesn't know if it
is a holy five what looks different
about this game to you okay well first
off the graphics are like leagues better
especially the animations the animations
were always something that kind of
bugged me with Mass Effect is I felt
like fairly early motion tracking sort
of thing this looks everything looks
super smooth the visuals are incredible
and we're meeting like a ton of new
races and that sort of stuff I'm all
about diversity yeah yeah diversify the
portfolio yeah yeah you got a black guy
hair a white guy here we did it has all
the races I'm super pumped for the game
um I gotta go play Mass Effect one
through three now just to prepare myself
for this why have you not play them I
have what you need to replay I need to
replay get too much time on your hands
to do that no wait hours a day to play
[ __ ] game I know but damn dude good
for you probably not be able to do it
all that time you play video games I'm
watching
episodes of It's Always Sunny in
Philadelphia ooh yeah just as rewarding
and just as mind stimulating so you're
excited for this game yes pumped cool
well that's my insight dan was not
necessary for this video no provide
commentary for this please subscribe to
the real regen we have a real old yank
the real Rico's I was not a part of it
at all dan that cyber channel on that
fiber channel and he's also going to be
doing some streaming on PGN and you can
follow him on instagram and twitter at
that Seibert guy and let's give a shout
out to a man who desperately needs more
followers yeah PewDiePie mmm PewDiePie
is struggling these days guys I saw like
he must have lost like a hundred
subscribers the other day yeah do
yourself a favor go watch PewDiePie go
watch PewDiePie and then tell them that
the real rejects yeah he'll be like feel
fanboy fanboy Oh still a boy those well
yeah I know we've been ignoring him for
a little bit we're trying to do a collab
I'm like not interested in that I don't
see a benefit from working with you what
we've been talking we think maybe now's
the time is the algorithm a typography
algorithm [ __ ] the YouTube algorithm